those arms touch them oh my goodness
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys and
today we have a very special guest we
have Mr Jared feather
you're kind of you're kind of big yeah
you know where did that come from where
it's all genetics so I just started
training yesterday
push-ups every day dude that's it so I
know I know Jared from the Fitness
industry he's a professional bodybuilder
um and he also has a master's degree in
what like exercise science basically
exercise physiology the emphasis is
exercise metabolism which is like the
biochemistry of nutrient breakdown in
the body brains
is it under the physiology
umbrella basically yeah okay so he knows
a lot of [__] and he's also strong as
[__] and he's [__] Jack I've known
him for years so basically you have a
hard on right now bar we both well also
every time so this is the thing every
time I talk about article this guy keeps
calling oh but you're the Hulk I'm like
I'm literally like I'm Spider-Man sorry
for complimenting you I'll never do it
again
in the Fitness World this guy's probably
like Captain America because there's
actual hulks that's like 300 pounds he's
talking down to you man okay
it's pretty cool I might actually be
Jane Gray
[Laughter]
Jubilee right now
still kind of good so I want to bring
someone else on so you guys could be
like okay this [__] that's how
we all are in our Fringe group though
right like there's a big guy in the
group and the friends are like you're so
massive and you're like nah I'm not
there's somebody else if you're not
massive what is it yeah
where does it go from here I mean
technically I'm like a classic physique
bro so there's a bunch of categories
there's men's physique cluster physique
and even some of the men's physique guys
are gigantic now it's like how many
pounds are those guys yeah uh depends
man they can get it used to be like more
of the beach fitness model look but it's
just gotten pretty obnoxious those guys
almost weigh as much on the over on the
overarching scale of the human body in
size from one to ten where you like
one's Hospital right oh God we talk
about him all the time
well we talk about them all the time
that's one
legit about that I'm like a five you got
to pick strong man into consideration
then you gotta take into a consideration
the freaks that you never hear about
that are like on an island somewhere in
Samoa and they're just lifting [__]
trees you know that kind of [__] happens
all the time if he's a fight then as
bull as a three
one two three four think about it I
didn't realize I was 3.6 we got to bring
decimals into this [__] that was
four foot and I'm five ten and then
Brian Charles six nine yeah right God I
don't know if Height's the only thing
that we should he's also 440 pounds okay
hundreds two of me so if I'm a five bro
you know the mountain from Game of
Thrones yeah so he's a strong man Thor
and he's what like six ten maybe yeah
he's basically Brian Charles metrics too
and he's like when he's lean he's like
350. yeah right he does bodybuilding
competitions or no he does a strong man
oh strong man but when he was like for
the show he leaned out he doesn't need
all that mass and after leaning out he
was like 350. have you seen his wife
she's fine oh yeah yeah what I feel like
all these big giant guys what's the
other guy's name the other biggest
stronger that's good they want the girl
to grab their dick like this
I feel like those dudes have like really
small wives is that a thing is that
that's not a thing are they just so big
that their wives look small but they're
actually taller than us I've heard
they're just normal ladies yeah
yeah it's two you got a small one I
don't have anyone but uh Brian Shaw's
wife is like six two I think and when
she stands next to him you think oh
that's a normal size
she's dunking on you oh man it's mail
order bride size small yeah yeah she's
like 5 10 and you're like oh she could
suck his dick standing up Jesus you're
probably good so how did you get into
bodybuilding because it's like a
lifelong commitment you have to dedicate
literally 24 hours it's like one of the
only 24 hour Sports yeah on sport you
know sorry guys it's nice
and that's coming from a professional
what do you call it I mean you know it's
a lifestyle whatever bodybuilding is a
beauty pageant legitimately if you
wouldn't watch Miss America and then you
wouldn't watch a bodybuilding show
you're like these have similarities then
you go watch football where people are
killing each other they're like this is
nothing body language what is this I
have a question about bodybuilding yeah
are there different uh like leagues or
like different governing groups or is it
just one technically there is but we're
looking for the corruption oh absolutely
was there corruption I was even gonna go
there the NPC is the biggest one for
like uh anybody who competes but there
are a bunch of natural organizations so
technically I was like a natural
professional bodybuilder for a long time
clearly not anymore
oh so some of them is some of them they
test for steroids and some of them they
don't correct no they test for them like
good like you gotta take it now you can
compete technically how you win you're
on the most Target nice no but yeah so
the ifbb NPC if you turn pro in the NPC
it's an ipv Pro there's a bunch of
federations like the nambf is huge in
the midwest OCB wnbf the World
Championships were out here last year I
almost I think you were in town that
weekend too and I hit you up then uh but
wbf is probably the big
natural bodybuilding Federation where
people want to turn pro there but
everyone looks like wack because
[Laughter]
it looks
smart it's just it just really points
out the genetic factor in bodybuilding
is all natural body got it and it points
out a lot of hard work too like you'll
see like 135 pound kid on stage but he
he's like glute striations and no body
fat and you're like damn I took a lot of
work but actually the natural
bodybuilder but then I was like do you
even lift bro some of them but the
natural body of a world champion just
won the Arnold Classic oh did you know
that oh no I didn't but it's natural
bodybuilding like WNBA and then the
steroid body buildings like NBA you
could compare it like that I think so
because everyone just cares about the
one when you look like an ox
the thing with Nat so when you're on
stage regardless if you're natural or
not you are like uh like a guy that
looks like so for me if I'm if you think
I'm big and I'm like 190-ish regular I
think you're like Spider-Man yeah
Spider-Man
no more compliments if I were to step on
stage I'd be at 160. that's how it's
like sucked in I am so when you see
these guys on stage they look like [__]
like everyone's like so [__] sucked
in to show all the striations but then
when you're on gear that's when it looks
sick because now it's like it's like
shrunken in but still jacked as well
what's on gear uh steroids oh yeah I
mean I'm here come on man get cool
steroids are all just fine they're cool
like so what are they graded on like
when someone comes in and then you're
like that one got big shoulders that got
bigger shoulders that's that's the
biggest shoulders and then that's like
that sounds a plus and then what about
the triceps biggest triceps it's like
that you should be a judge technically
like actual criteria they're supposed to
go by but sometimes you look at the show
and you're like they they just threw the
[__] out the window like what was
that it's like symmetry like upper lower
symmetry then like side to side Symmetry
and uh getting lean is the most I'll say
this like nobody ever says this but
getting Molina is the most important
thing in bodybuilding if you are the
biggest guy with the nicest shape is
what they call it like big delts and all
that [__]
um but you're just like 10 pounds fat
too fat to be on stage you're just not
winning this so if you're like a
negative percent body fat almost dead
you're definitely dead and everyone's
like that's the guy yeah so basically
it's just muscle and skin yeah I mean
chicks that are competing on stage some
of them will stop their period for like
what like a month because their hormones
all out of whack I mean you know if you
get into the real nitty-gritty of shitty
ass coaches out there yeah some of them
will stop their period indefinitely oh
my God especially the anabolic using
females like they get [__] over big
time because there's so much
misinformation out there but hopefully
well because women need a little bit of
fat to be healthy huh I mean everybody
does it's not a healthy thing to do
getting that lean like currently right
now my brain hardly works but we're
making it work so your brain hard Lewis
because you're you said you were
preparing your 10 days out is that what
you said yeah so I'm technically eight
days out like tomorrow would be the
start of my peak week for my first show
of the Year well so as a show like you
also mentioned that you uh are on some
stuff like you're allowed to there are
certain shows that you can just like
everybody's like yeah on gear NPC ipb is
just like yeah you're you're taking some
sort of uh performance enhancing drug
whether it is anabolic steroids or like
Bible Brigade protein stuff like that
that's definitely performance strength
today we have a lot of testosterone
something like that so it doesn't
necessarily have to be so if you wanted
to break this up a peed is anything that
provides some sort of benefit uh to you
for the sport you're in so if you wanted
to go further there's AAS which is
androgenic anabolic steroids which is
what most people think about when they
think about peeds because technically
Adderall could be a peat if you're like
a a race car driver modafinil and I'm
definitely not on that right now
it's like the only real nootropic it's
it's uh it acts on a different pathway
but it's for like people who have night
shift disorder the [__] is that nurses
and stuff like that doctors who have to
go into like 24-hour shifts and stuff so
they just stay up and their brains just
keep going and that's just called speed
you know it's kind of like what's that
movie the [__] is that movie called a
limitless Limitless Limitless yeah that
movie too
today's video is brought to you by Warby
Parker Warby Parker offers you
everything you need for happier eyes
eyeglasses sunglasses contact lenses and
even eye exams and you can shop with
them online or in stores classes start
at 95 including prescription lenses try
Warby Parker's free home try on program
order five pairs of glasses to try on at
home for free there's no obligation to
buy ships free and also includes a
prepaid return shipping label you can
also add a pair and save get 15 off when
you purchase two or more pairs of
prescription eyeglasses or sunglasses
it's pretty awesome you can go on the
website take an at-home quiz you can
start picking out your glasses the kit
comes straight to your door and you can
put it in front of the mirror and look
at yourself and be like dude do these
look like the glasses that I saw online
does it look like pretty cool on the
bridge of my nose does it fit is it nice
does it match with this outfit and you
get to try that on before you commit try
five pairs of glasses at home for free
at warbyparker.com off the Record if you
recommend modafinil I'm not gonna say I
recommend
I wouldn't recommend anything so you
endorse my usage can you hook me up with
your contact so how does modafinil help
with uh your like what you're trying to
do like I said my brain just doesn't
work currently like it's very hard to
hold conversations and things like that
oh yeah
right right you're uh when you're brain
blood glucose gets pretty low that's
whenever you start to experience that
kind of fogginess and [__] like that
yeah people who have been on a ketogenic
diet for a long time they can
technically function prop decently but I
mean you know still some of the dumbest
people I've ever met but
slam
who cuts out whole food groups I mean
come on yeah you get pretty dumb okay
put body for bodybuilding competitions
is it like you say it was like a beauty
pageant right is there like a sinking
portion and a dance portion and like a
you talk about world peace and stuff
yeah like different kinds of portion
afterwards the winner does uh I mean
there's a posing routine that's like
dancing right A lot of people making
routine remember that Viral went back in
the natural days where the dudes [__]
just pop yeah he'll like do the robot
and shoot the best one it is are there
like some standard poses that everyone
does when they're up there yeah because
like the ones from the lat spread so the
one let's get apart let's go I actually
helped him through an entire uh posing
yeah can I see him
so different and this is like the whole
whole shape changes right it looks crazy
let's see wait wait is this the 11
minute 30 second holy [__] yeah I feel
like I feel like you're supposed to take
off your shirt yeah this is it's every
guest does it and Anthony you take off
your shirt and you do a front last but
yeah yeah we all do a front last
reference keep your pants on otherwise
we're getting demonetized
no later hot to you yes or two so I
guess like um having someone as smart as
you want would be a a good time to like
maybe some questions about steroids so I
think the common conception is like you
know how a lot of people they see
someone that's big or strong and they go
all right if I was on steroids I'll be
that big and strong like is it like that
is it a miracle and then
um I think the papa pal comes after them
there's more sound effects yeah it's
kind of like
this is gonna get really like silly and
philosophical but when you guys started
doing this and you started blowing up
and you realize you're really good at
talking and bullshitting with each other
your Affinity to that thing just was
really high yeah so you kept doing it
and you blew up on YouTube like I think
the first video I saw was your [__]
mic change six-pack shortcuts bro that
video is the OG video like I don't know
if you guys knew them back then did you
no they contacted us after oh wait these
guys yeah yeah Mike Jane contacted you
guys yeah what's my chain on steroids
was he on camera likely likely right
yeah trt because I would see this big
ass I don't know if you guys remember
him but he was this massive dude and
he's like just curl towels and I'm like
bro I think you're on steroids
paper towel he's the funniest [__]
put that link in this video because God
damn everybody needs to see that [__]
again that I quoted that thing probably
my entire freshman year at college
you guys knew you were good at it you
were funny so you're like let's keep
[__] doing that thing with steroids
it's most people get into the gym and
they don't just start shooting [__]
stairs all the way right like that would
be silly some kids do I guess Tick Tock
things Tick Tock [__]
um
big ass black dudes touch a weight and
then they get [__] even bigger and
they're like wow I'm good at this [__]
and then they decide to go do steroids
and blah blah but it's the beginning
part where it's like this guy just
gained 30 pounds of muscle in like a
year of training clearly he's gonna be
[__] good at that thing then they get
on steroids and they get bigger and
bigger and bigger whatever if they were
to say natural they would have been I
don't know the natural body but a world
championship like I told you about who
just won the Arnold Classic
um so when people who just don't have
that good genetics say [__] like if I
were on steroids I'm like shut the [__]
up because genetics matter so much more
this is not even funny and even just
let's see a growth resistant right like
you hit the gym Hardy on a sick program
or your diet is good but over three
years your body doesn't really transform
someone like that even if they touched
gear it wouldn't have that kind of like
exponential they would obviously put on
muscle but it probably wouldn't be at
the same rate as somebody who is more
androgenic anyway because the reason
those people gain so much muscle is
there's there are like a multitude of
factors but a big portion of that is
like their Androgen receptors are highly
like the affinity for testosterone to
bind to them is super high so they build
a bunch of lean tissue which is why like
people have higher testosterone which is
why I say like jacked athletic black
dudes they generally have higher
testosterone to begin with all black
teas are [__] Jacks yeah this is it's
just a fact of the matter Polynesians
did you know that they yes
disproportionately
um represent a lot of a lot of the
athletes like the NFL football legit no
that's a real small population but a lot
of popular Polynesia that's why I said
like somebody on a [__] Island yeah
like Samoa they're just like wow that
guy just dead looked at 800 pounds yeah
um you watch a football game in uh High
School Hawaii like dude oh it's insane
they're bigger than yeah they're three
times me yeah did you ever watch that
one show like locked up or whatever
where they showcase all these jails they
showcase this one woman gel oh boy and
then throws a Samoan lady she goes I
never lost she's the queen and I was
like I wonder why
it's like all these my [__] even the
guards my [__] all the inmates are
like right here just shocking people
like of course it's unfair advantage
but yeah just like it's a true Testament
to like genetics are the most important
thing and even just your genetic
tolerance for drugs is a thing so that
kid who was putting on 10 pounds over
the last five years who didn't really
have a high affinity for growing muscle
to begin with
he's probably not going to be growing
that much muscle tissue when he starts
antibiotic steroids and generally you
see a lot of other things with that too
like they just have more side effects so
then you see the people with like the
[__] crazy back acne and it's like
okay well that kid just should not have
touched steroids ever like it would have
been smart for him to just stay natural
be healthy go be a [__] computer
engineer like you know I did a seminar
in India and I was just wanted to tell
everybody like stop looking at my calves
I'm a dumbass go be an engineer like
that's what I wanted to say at the
seminar like we're done here why what if
I know a guy took steroids probably the
wrong way got crazy back acne yeah he
got off and then he got back on is that
smart of him to do that side effects
aren't the same every single time and
there's a lot of Downstream stuff
happening as far as physiology goes that
creates the actual acne the cystic acne
portion yeah there's stuff like Accutane
out there there's stuff like even uh
metformin has been shown to reduce acne
quite a bit which is technically a type
2 diabetic drug which is crazy so the
acne isn't a like indicator of whether
or not steroids is being received well
by you
um not necessarily but people do
contribute side effects to what's
working quite a bit which is silly as
[__] but that's how a lot of these
dumbasses do it like
it's [__] working
the reason people like Trend which you
guys have probably heard of Trin like
it's said all the time I don't think
they have so maybe you can explain the
spectrum of steroids because there's
crazy [__] and then there's like even
girls take but you don't even know yeah
our understanding is like three you know
because there's stuff that's so mild
um like that'd be like anavar right like
some chicks just take it and just like
gives that nice little bikini body maybe
even the Casual gym chick might take it
but you don't know she just wants to
look and by take it are you saying all
these things are inject you inject this
stuff a lot of them are mostly injected
so most anabolic steroids are injectable
okay um but there are oral forms it's
just anything oral's a little bit more
hepatotoxic so it's like liver toxic oh
if you're taking an oral steroid which
is why I would never say like what he
just said there's more mild and safer
they're technically more mild but
they're not [__] mild like anything
anabolic an antibiotic steroids no he's
not wrong it's just he's just I don't I
don't like putting things that way
because I don't want people to be like
okay so anavar yeah you know what I mean
like this wouldn't be a good idea
especially for females because they can
viralize like get male characteristics
pair voice all that [__] get smarter
what if you want more male characters
what are the what is the so it's there
isn't a severity Spectrum like no there
could be because a lot of the what are
called 19 nors it's just the way the
compound is like Cleaves during making
it so trend
um nandralone these types of they're
like they sound crazy just sub steroids
um like space stations legit they all
Branch from the testosterone group right
um but those things cause a little bit
more like neurotoxicity too which is
what I was thinking about the point with
like yeah legit yeah sharers are being
shown to like kind of downgrade your
intelligence a little bit because oh man
Trend alone is the one where people get
really [__] aggressive so if you're
already a dick right in your day-to-day
life it just makes you more of a dick is
that called a Roid Rage yes exactly
that's where it comes from but it's
technically not even roid Ridge it's
like these things bring out people's
personalities more than they already
have oh okay just amplifies what you got
also if you mean you mean if you're a
crybaby you cry a lot 100 yeah but Trent
is one of those ones where you really
[__] feel it
um you feel like that that
neurostimulative property where you're
like kind of angry in the gym and you
want to push a bunch of [__] weight
so when people feel that and they see a
little bit of acne and they see like oh
my Skin's getting red too because that's
another thing that happens with a lot of
steroids they're like okay this is
working or they get on something like
nandra loan which is another 19 or I
mentioned and they gain like 10 pounds
of water weight right away so then
they're like oh this is working but
really they get off that and then they
lose that 10 pounds and they really only
gained a pound of muscle so it's like
people associate the side effects way
too much with what works that's really a
terrible mentality well I don't know if
this works but I was at Costco and I got
a supplement that said testosterone
health and I got it
so uh you look huge you look healthy
Sanders is definitely working that acne
is coming in strong Joe do any of those
like testosterone boosters work that are
like uh over the OTC no no probably not
um but I mean it's a damage you know
there are
stuff yeah yeah there's vitamins and
minerals in a lot of those ethereal
magnesium it's got ashwagandha it's got
zinc so all those things have I think
makes you huge the reason those things
get put in those supplements is because
somebody realizes oh zinc is what's on
the Androgen receptor site for Affinity
binding which is why people take zinc
when they're on steroids but if they're
not on steroids it's probably not doing
much for you but it doesn't mean that
taking actions are cold so yeah it
doesn't mean that taking extra zinc's a
bad thing it's just you probably don't
have a deficiency in that and it likely
is you're just kind of wasting it but
that's why like
um one of the vitamins are kind of like
a shotgun approach and you don't really
need them technically so you should
probably find what you're deficient in
and then that's what you to supplement
with if you need to but a healthy
balanced diet is really all you ever
need for that [__] and just losing
weight staying healthy and things like
that are the best thing you can do to
boost your natural testosterone this guy
right here check that out dude squeeze
give me a squeeze this is how you angle
yeah we need we need better uh
watch feel his arms I don't want my
fingers to disintegrate touch them
[Laughter]
what a dude
wow
[Laughter]
my mom's calves look exactly like that
so those are wow
what's in there that's a rock
foreign